honestly feel like um
it's because we've started catering to
the people who are traumatized so like
i'm not i'm not saying they shouldn't
get help what i'm saying is
that having things like trigger warnings
right there's stuff like exposure
therapy for a reason but if we start
like
saying oh yeah this person can't hear
that then it's just gonna like set them
up to be triggered for it you know what
i mean like so if
it becomes normalized and you hear it
day-to-day
then like you're not going to be
triggered and if it still triggers you
that's when you have to go and seek
therapy
right to to better yourself for me it's
it it's really frustrating to see
mental health and trauma get users
almost like buzzwords in today's society
because i've seen it in my family i've
seen it firsthand people going through
some real [ __ ] so when people just like
start using like oh i'm going for a
minute i'm going through it's like like
from an ex-boyfriend it's like trauma's
supposed to be from like war
not an x that like cheated on you
exactly when we use them examples people
like
will say
i think because every society every
every generation builds a new set of
problems right so it's like
yes we have different problems as to
problems that they have 50 years ago but
we need to understand that the world we
live in it's much better than it was 100
years ago like we need to
understand that and embrace it and stop
using everything as well
because i think i think the problem with
it is like
my brother went through mental health
and i think when i was watching him go
for it it was a 10-year
10-year span him getting better and
worse and on and off
and the best advice i gave at first i
was very sympathetic
and i was like oh don't worry we're here
to help you when he got better is when i
was harsh with him i said look no one's
here to save you no bro you keep doing
this keep doing that that's you bro
that's when he started to realize when i
was more empathetic with him in sympathy
with him he was getting worse because he
had someone to kind of lean on and just
enable i think the same way like the
last like breakup i was in it was kind
of like what
because i really only talked to my
family about that sort of stuff um for
the most part and my dad was just like
shut up
he's like shut up it's over yeah move on
and i was just like
damn yeah
and did you die no i did i was like you
know what he's right he's right if
anything you actually you know you can
move on with your life because you'll
never get it back the time that we waste
yeah that's what that's what my dad said
that's the best thing i think one of the
best things look forward let's my dad
always tells me he's like look forward
you can't you literally can't change the
past and even even my dad he had like a
tough childhood yeah and growing up
people would like
there were comments that he should like
go to therapy about it or whatever and
his mindset was just like why it's over
like what am i what's what's talking
about it gonna do like you want me to
talk about my problems
yeah
you know what's interesting though he
was doing something called radical
acceptance and that's something that's
done in therapy so he just did his own
therapy oh so therapy is not like that's
just built differently yeah because look
so many everybody's different so it's
not like therapy just being in a room
and the same results yeah he did his own
therapy and you just have to radically
accept things
are the way they are and i just move on
oh i accept that okay maybe i yeah i got
bullied because i'm ugly yeah i have to
accept that i'm not a ten yeah move on
it's kind of like a sub topic i don't
know if you know when morgan freeman he
does he um
i think he got asked in like an
interview they're like oh
how do we get over racism and he said
stop talking about it
and then i was at first it's about when
i first saw that about eight years ago i
was like what the hell's this guy
talking about black man on tv saying
stop talking maurice is it not but when
i got old and i realized hold on he's
bang on because it's just like we're
talking about trauma like or mental
health like you get over things by just
moving on cracking on
moving forward if we all think about our
darkest and deep times i think about
them and when i think about them it
makes me feel worse
i don't want to talk about i want to
crack on and as soon as i got that harsh
reality bro no one's here to save you
keep moving that's when i felt better i
just feel like life is so short you're
never going to be younger than you are
now you're never going to have more
energy than you are now like and that's
what
i don't know i always try to get things
done like as quickly as i can because
you just never know how much time you
got left
and it's like you're gonna spend the
time you have worried about some [ __ ]
that happened yesterday i can't change
it yeah i think the thing is is that
we're all of us here are more on the
practical side even the girls so yes of
course i'm the same as you
but
i from my experience as someone as a
more of a clinician
i've realized that there are different
they're different personality they're
just personality disorders there are
people who think very differently from
us and the problem you see them in
feminism is that the problem is that
they don't know how to deal with the
trauma so it turns into hate it turns
into feminism it turns into trying to
exile an entire gender
that's that's that's the problem because
certain people i guess certain people
are great with dealing with trauma they
know how to deal with themselves some
people can't and the problem with them
is that they can't or choose not to
you don't think because again throughout
all of human history like we had wars we
had famine we had all of these horrible
horrible things like you don't think on
some level it's a choice
i think the difficulty as well as that
part of it is for example precise orders
um they are actually cultivated from
childhood and they are very prominent
very prevalent in broken families people
who have the wrong type of father and
mother figures and it's very sad because
what happens is the child
they don't they learn they don't learn
how to
basically be an adult and and deal with
things in adult way so they do very if
you see it basically they're very
childish in the way they do things they
they thought anger tantrums don't we
think that can i just quickly because i
think this is important yeah don't we
don't well i got the answer anyone
asking me don't we don't we think that
adding all these different personality
disorders is the problem i've got
because i've seen it as a kid so i went
to a normal school you know
rough kids could whatever was a bit of a
mixture and
an interruptive or dismissive child oh
he's got adhd
this other kid he's got that he's got
that but it's like we it's like a
self-fulfilling prophecy you you label a
12 year old with adhd he's gonna grow
he's gonna i've seen kids use as an
excuse i've got adhd i can't control
myself well i got this because they've
been diagnosed at such a young age with
such issues it's like you just live you
just live on it's just not like
you can't even with adhd you can't do
anything about it otherwise then put
yourself on ritalin from like being a
child which doesn't seem like a because
honestly they um
like i'm pretty energetic you know
and i've been like people have diagnosed
me i would say diagnosed because it's so
easy to get diagnosed i don't i don't
even count it
but
it's like but i was like what am i going
to do i could take drugs and it's like
you don't sleep on the drugs so i was
like i don't want to do that and my
other choice is to make excuses and say
that's everything and i just just like
no i'll just be normal
the other thing is that there's
you might know more about this about the
dsm and the fact that mental illnesses
there's a there's a debate in what
actually is a mental illness like a
an actual one or are you just catering
to the patient if the patient says i'm
feeling this way
uh i don't know there was a i'm not sure
what it means but some sorry i can't
forget i forgot what the actual uh term
is but if a woman's been abused
from grape
mentioned it first time um
then
there's some sort of uh she's she has a
mental illness that says that she's she
wanted that to happen or something like
really some it just i don't know if
you're familiar what i'm talking about
are you saying that like
from what they learn from their parents
or from past experiences and predisposes
them again for it in the future no girl
girls are turned on